hello everyone recently i posted a
conversation i had
with michael yan an esteemed author and
combat correspondent on the populist
uprisings the farmers uprisings the
truckers uprisings the yellow jackets
and so forth in europe and the potential
spread of what's
called so nicely by the u n foods
insecurity across the world michael had
spent some time with the dutch farmers
as well who haven't been represented
well i would say in the legacy media for
reasons that aren't exactly clear
we he reached out to a dutch farmer
jeroen van maanen
to provide a first-hand account of the
matter and to discuss the dutch farmers
concerns and we thought it would be very
useful to bring that to you in the
context of this broader discussion
so
on to that
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen this
is uh
i'm a dairy farmer from
zerolder
a city in the middle of the netherlands
someone asked me if i could
send a message what's going on in
holland what's all about these farmer
protests and why are dutch farmers angry
well the farmer protests are already
here since uh
two and a half years the first of
october 2019 was the first time dutch
farmers had a very big protest
we all went to the egg
and actually there was more like some
protests
about the wind which was blowing already
probably for 30 years that somewhere
there's a problem in the environment
there's a problem with pollution
agriculture sector gets pointed at as a
main cause of all problems
after that after the biggest protest
nitrogen problems came up and nitrogen
problems aren't new 30 years ago already
nature people start talking about
nitrogen pollution
which would make the rain sour and all
the sour rain
would cause lots of damage to the nature
parks to forest
and when you would hear these voices
all the nature would be gone in a few
years
well thirty years later nature's still
there most of it is in excellent
condition
for two and a half years people start
talking about nitrogen emission ammonia
from agriculture sector
there's also
nitrogen pollution because of the
traffic because of the industry
nitrogen oxides
but we don't talk about it a lot and
when the nitrogen problem is cold in
holland it's focusing uh most of the
times
on the agriculture sector only
well
when the thing started
and actually what i wanted to do is
reducing the nitrogen emission and
especially the nigerian deposition on
nature parks
well it started agriculture sector came
together all parties like the the dairy
industry pork industry chicken industry
you could ever call whatever industries
came together made a big plan
there was a lot of solutions in it
and we tried to to solve the problem
our government in the meanwhile we
went on with making other plans
which resulted in uh
the latest new plan a few weeks ago
and it's uh terrible it's idiot and it's
and it's of no use
what they did is they divided holland in
different regions
some regions have to lower their
emissions by 12
some regions have to lower their
emissions by 46.
75 or 95 percent
in the meanwhile our juridical system is
this on this moment that no innovations
in agriculture sector are allowed to use
so there are different techniques for uh
lowering your omission but when you are
asked for a court and a judge will look
into your innovations they will say you
can't use it so the only reason the only
thing
to
lower your emissions right now is just
cutting your heart back
and actually you're probably coming
at the main cause of it all
stick uh nitrogen is more like we call
it stick to beat the dog
it's just to camouflage the real cars
some left-wing parties in holland and
probably all over the world it's it's
the same movement they want to get rid
of
animal industries they want to have a
transition to more plant-based food
transition to
vegetarians we have all the all the
older stuff together
in ireland we also have a party like
that and they asked for 50 reduction of
our national herd that's probably on
this moment the main cause of it all
we're not talking about nitrogen no they
just want to reduce the national earth
well every farmer all around the world
and also every citizen knows
that cutting back the hood isn't the
cause of the of any problems you know we
are producing food
two-thirds of agricultural land on the
planet can only be grown by grass and
you need
cows like this
for making grass into meat or into milk
or whatever you want
whatever problem with emissions with
pollution on the world you are asking
about whether it's not chemical
but farming is probably a part of the
problem but most of it all it's
part of the solution
well dutch farmers now are getting
angry every day more government is not
listening
and what we are fearing for is we have
to leave our land and that's also
a deeper agenda behind it
in holland they just want to have
farmers land 62 percent of the
area in holland is farmed by farmers
and what they want to do is they want to
have the land cheap so they're making it
nature
first
and when they have the land in their
hands they can build houses on it houses
we don't need by
dutch citizens
because average dutch couple is getting
1.8 1.9 kids so what's the problem of
the
demand for houses that we get 100 000
refugees refugees in the in this country
every year
that's why they have to build houses
well that's a shortcut of
of our problems right now
farmers are getting angry they're not
listened by by the government
every solution we
came on with
they don't take it
and what we see right now when we have
to reduce our national hurt when we have
to reduce our herds by ourselves farms
will break down on this moment when the
plan of the government is coming
probably 30 40 50 of the farmers have to
fear for the future that's why we're on
the streets that's why we're protesting
that's why the protesters are going
harder
and
actually quite happily
all around the world people start
looking at holland what's happening
there
well what uh what the warning from the
dutch farmers is that every citizen from
holland especially but also in europe
probably around the globe
have to look at what do we want to have
to eat in the in a few years time dutch
agriculture is champion world champion
on every class whether we talk about
nitrogen where we talk about other
pollutions
dutch farming is best in all chapters
so it's no solution to
get rid of dutch farmers the production
which is uh
going away up here needs to come back in
enough in another different area from
the world
well we need transport for that it gives
co2 emissions
and also the standards of production up
there
aren't as high as as in dutch
agriculture so that's why we're fighting
on the street we want to stay on our
land
when we are part of a problem we want to
solve it we can do it we always did it
nitrogen pollution and nitrogen
emissions
turned back 68 by agriculture sector in
holland in the last 30 years so we
proved we can do a lot of things but we
will keep on farming we will fight for
our farms
that's why we
have the actions we have the protest on
the on the on the in the country
we're asking a lot of attention for our
problems
this is uh in ireland we call it a
farmer's handkerchief and it's made a
symbol of the of the battle of the
farmers right now
and actually
it feels good that
foreign people asking for what's
happening in holland and we're warning
you all over europe
this problem which is here in holland
can be your problem in the next years so
we're asking for support from farmers
and also citizens in europe all around
the world
this problem could be your problem when
citizens want to have
food on the on the plate in the next 10
years
that we have to stand up for our farmers
dutch farmers are standing up
we are supporting all farmers around the
world
keep on doing what we do and we have to
start fighting for our farms for our
future for our families and for food and
table thanks very much